قف
[موسيقى]
توقف السيد الرئيس بكل صعوبة
أنت ذاهب لما نفعله
هناك محادثات ربما السيد كل زون
قد تكون هذه الزيارة إلى تركيا
ما بين أثنين
رئيس الوزراء بنيتين في هذه النقاط
لا تزال هناك بعض الأساليب الإيجابية.
هل رأيته هكذا
[موسيقى]
هذه
مهلا لماذا كتب أنك ضعيف جدا
الق نظرة مهملة على نفسك
تعطينا نحن نتعامل
لكن مشكلتك ليست متفوقة
[موسيقى]
أين كانت إسرائيل والآن هي إسرائيل الآن
لا توجد فلسطين
تقريبا كل من
[موسيقى]
الاقتصاد مع إسرائيل التجارة والسياحة
علاقاتنا في الميدان
إنه يتقدم في مسار إسرائيل
في سياق جهود السلام ، خالص و
لا يوجد موقف بناء
تساهم بلا شك في عملية التطبيع
سيعثر عليه
اشترك
هو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالقتل فأنت جيد جدًا في القتل
أنت تعرف
كيف قتلت الاطفال على الشواطئ
كان يعرف جيدًا كيف ضربت
[موسيقى]
هو هو